[موسيقى]
لقد ادركنا سريعا اي الرئيس شيراك ادرك
سريعا في عام 2002 انه كان هناك رغبه
واضحه كل الوضوح من جانب الامريكي لاحداث
تغيير في النظام في
العراق فمحور الشر الذي
اشير اليه كان يهدف للتخلص من صدام حسين
وبالنسبه لشراك فان الدول يكون لها قاده
تختارها شعوبهم وليس دول اجنبيه فشعوب هي
التي تختار القاده ثم تحل اي مشكلات مع
هؤلاء القاده اذا الرئيس شيراك وفي حوار
في نهايه عام 2002 بمناسبه قمه لحلف
النيتو مع الرئيس بوش قال له اذا تدخلتم
في العراق
هذه العمليه ستكون اولا غير قانونيه وغير
شرعيه ولن تحصل على دعم من المجتمع الدولي
والنتيجه نتيجه هذه العمليه ستكون زعزعه
استقرار المنطقه برمتها
[موسيقى]
رئيس بشرى انزعج كثير من هذا الموقف وكان
لدينا شعور انذاك وتاكد ذلك عندما ارسلني
الرئيسي راقي واشنطن في بدايه عام 2003
قبل الحرب باسابيع ادركنا ان الهدف كان
تغيير النظام في العراق
[موسيقى]